(bouncy violin music)
- This has always been an obsession.
Everybody collects something
and mine just happens to be antlers.
(lively chiming music)
My name is Jim Phillips,
and I'm the Antler Man.
I have over 16,000 antlers.
I didn't kill all these
animals to get the antlers.
I'm not much of a killer.
Deer and elk and moose and
antelope shed their antlers
every year and grow a new set of antlers.
I just started walkin' out in the hills
and I would find one and
pick it up and bring it home.
There is no harm to the animal.
I have good days and bad days.
The most deer antlers I
ever found in a day was 87.
But I've hiked 11 hours
and never found an antler.
I keep my antlers in a shed
that I built at my house.
It is 60 feet long and 30 feet wide.
There's a pattern to everything in here
and the way the antlers are
laid out, that's the art.
The reason I guess I display
the antlers the way I do,
respect for the antler,
respect for the animal itself.
The shed may seem full,
but when I look around
I can still find places
to put the antlers.
As long as I can get out and
get around in the mountains,
I'll continue to collect.
I get the same thrill
today, 59 years later,
as I did when I was a 10-year-old
and there's very few things
you can say that about.
My wife has plans on me stopping.
My daughters have a plan on me stopping,
but I have no plans on ever stopping.
(chiming)